virage relevé là c'est pentu ou encore
chemin roche pas de doute la colline
d'Élancourt est presque prête pour la
compétition depuis plusieurs mois elle
est en cours d'aménagement par la
société de livraison des ouvrages
olympiques zone spectateur espace
logistique mais surtout piste de plus de
4 km la solideo délivrera à la fin du
mois de juillet un aménagement clé en
main et soucieux de l'écosystème
environnant la piste est quasiment
terminée il nous reste à peu près un
mois pour finaliser certains ouvrages on
a certains tremplins en bois par exemple
ici qui vont être réalisés dans les
quatre semaines à venir on a pris un
certain nombre de dispositions aussi
pour réduire le plus possible les
impacts du chantier de l'événement par
exemple il y a aucun éclairage qui est
mis en place qui perturbe pas donc la
faune la nuit par exemple il y a les
clôtures de sécurité du chantier qui ont
été surélevées pour permettre le passage
de la petite faune il y a des espaces
qui sont sanctuarisés la piste sera
expérimentée les 23 et 24 septembre
nombreux prochains par les meilleurs
vététistes mondiaux lors d'un test event
une répétition grandeur nature de
l'épreuve de cross country olympique de
Paris 2024 l'objet pour Paris 2024 c'est
donc de tester de toutes les façons
possibles le site par exemple de voir si
les pompiers peuvent bien passer pour
intervenir si besoin par exemple de voir
si la piste est pas trop dangereuse pour
les athlètes par exemple de voir si
c'est facile du point de vue de la
retransmission de l'événement après les
Jeux place à l'héritage l'objectif est
de faire de la colline un parc sportif
et paysager pour les habitants du
territoire
recréant de nouvelles pistes avec des
nouveaux difficultés différents du
mobilier sportif des agrets ludiques
pour les enfants la conservation de la
piste naturellement la piste olympique
ça va servir de de support de
compétition l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
réaccueillir une compétition des
entraînements à des niveaux très
importants dans le futur les épreuves de
VTT des jeux se dérouleront les 28 et 29
juillet 2024 aucun véhicule ne sera
autorisé sur place les 15000 spectateurs
attendus devront se rendre sur le site
en navette